Scott cofin has long been vocal about
ensuring that the movie will be
something that the Five Nights at
Freddy's fan base will want to see but
who exactly is that fan base the FNAF
games have a DieHard online following
that mostly consists of men in their 20s
and 30s but anyone who's walked through
any establishment that sells books has
surely seen the withered faces of the
Fazbear animatronics staring up from the
kid section plus the movie has a killer
cast with an indie horror director at
the helm so it might just manage to
appeal to viewers old young and new why
do I always get to wear those there's a
campy heartfelt energy on display in the
Five Nights at Freddy's trailers as well
as no shortage of jump scares it looks
like a delightful mix of the horror
comedy of the child's play series as
well as the spooky lore of a Nightmare
on Elm Street Five Nights at Freddy's
could also attract the familyfriendly
horror audience of something like
stranger things our prediction and hope
is that it will land somewhere near
Megan on the scary versus silly scale